Film Courage: Common misconceptions about
what a writer should do after their script
is finished?
Travis Seppala, Screenwriter/Author: Let’s
see one is getting your script registered
with the WGA [Writers Guild of America] versus
having it copyrighted versus mailing it to
yourself.
I’ve seen many writers who still believe
that if you mail your script to yourself that
counts as a copyright.
No it does not.
It will not hold up in court.
The only thing that will hold in court is
a copyright where it has an official document
attached and said this script was copyrighted
on this date.
WGA registration is still better than mailing
it to yourself but it’s not quite as good
as a copyright especially with the way they
change their registration and stuff only goes
like overall.
It doesn’t go per draft.
Whereas with copyrighting you’re going to
want to copyright each thing that way you
get proof of it.
It’s a little more expensive to copyright
but it’s the safest thing if one of those
very rare stealings ever happen.
Film Courage: What is a paranoid screenwriter?
Travis: People who are afraid their stuff
is going to get taken.
People who won’t send their stuff out to
competitions, won’t send their stuff out
to producers without an NDA.
Never send an NDA to a producer and be like
“Oh you can’t read my script until…”
No, they will just give you your NDA back
and be like “Well I don’t need to read
your script.”
Which I have met several people who think
that they need to send an NDA out in order
to get a producer to read…no.
The producer is not going to sign the NDA.
You need to sign an NDA for the producer possibly
if you want to work on the project that they’re
needing to hire a writer for to save their
butts.
You are not going to take their idea and go
write it yourself without them.
But they will not sign an NDA for you.